1961 première apparition de la célèbre
4l sur les routes françaises
cinquante ans plus tard elle a toujours
autant d'admirateurs
ce que j'aime dans la 4l c'est vraiment
le b à ba du véhicule mais c'est très
simple à conduire à pratiquer on peut
sortir là vous savez tout ce qui est
siège vous pouvez sortir vous mettre
dehors tout de suite et on pique nique
vraiment la simplicité aussi passe
partout mes parents ils ont roulé en 4l
pendant des années des années
c'est une histoire de famille c'est plus
vieux que nous disent à quoi c'est quand
même exceptionnel
près de 1200 4 elles ont investi les
circuits du val de loire depuis vendredi
trois mille personnes déambulent entre
les véhicules des amateurs des
nostalgiques mais aussi des
collectionneurs
yvonnick est tombé dedans il ya 35 ans
dans les années 70 80 90 qu'embrouiller
en 4l vous étiez un regard quoi possible
alors qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu un
objet tout le monde se retourne vous
pensez que votre 4l tout le monde se
retourne dessus donc c'est une revanche
à peu sur le voilà tout ce que j'ai pu
entendre à droite à gauche que quand je
roulais en 4 est vendu à plus de 8
millions d'exemplaires la renault 4
réputé pour sa fiabilité avait surtout
une fonction pratique pour les familles
aujourd'hui elle rejoint les voitures de
collection ce qui attire les gens je
pense que c'est vraiment les valeurs que
véhicule cette voiture c'est le partage
la convivialité c'est de se retrouver
autour d'une passion commune
on a de tous les âges en a de tous les
types de véhicules et chacun se respecte
dans sa manière d'avoir de voir la 4l de
voir la restauration d'origine pur très
pure ou autre est bien pour aller faire
des raids
aventure avec des 4l bariolé de toutes
les couleurs le plus grand rassemblement
au monde de quatre elle continue jusqu'à
demain 19h comme quoi la belle n'a pas
encore tiré sa révérence